Justin Warner here the man with the fans
and in order to get in the spirit my
friends check it out
how cool is that these are the uh Black
Panther claws uh produced by Hasbro and
uh they're really putting me in the
spirit of things uh you know you can
show off your fiercest wakandan salute
you got lights you got actions and man
that sounds sharp speaking of sharp uh
I'm over here with Brandon and Brandon
you're looking mighty good uh Justin
thank you man
um so I understand you're a huge black
panther fan and I gotta I gotta know can
you tell us a little bit about your
cosplay tonight of course so what I'm
actually wearing is King Azuri who's a
grandfather of King tutala so wow so you
got the whole family lineage and
everything yeah eventually I'm gonna do
king of Shaka too along with black
panther so as a Black Panther fan I
gotta know what inspires you from the
film
really what inspires me most is that in
scene where wakanda finally makes a
decision to open up his borders to the
world to share technology because Unity
I feel like is what it's all about
working together with other nations
working with other cultures and stuff
and I love what Marvel and Disney how
they incorporate more and more cultures
set in a tone that we as you know
African-Americans and people of color
had never seen before so this is
groundbreaking for me so we chatted a
little bit before and I think it's not
just important for uh people of our age
but for the Next Generation as well and
I understand that you have a little
cosplayer waiting for you at home yes my
son Braxton uh we love doing cosplay
together I love dressing up he loves
dressing up with me and we go to cons
and stuff like that we have so much fun
together well Braxton my friend is your
lucky day because in partner with Hasbro
we're handing out the Marvel Legends
black panther premium electronic helmet
and black panther wakanda FX battleclaw
so that's awesome thanks marble thank
you right there for you man hot diggity
dog today is a good day
uh and for all of you at home you can of
course get your black panther wakanda
battle FX claws uh your local Target
Walmart or online at Amazon and uh I
just gotta know I I wonder do you think
Hasbro makes a set of matching ABS man I
hope they do make a set of matching ABS
because you know I got dad Bots a little
imagine ABS to go with this Hasbro if
you haven't I need it I need it